hello there it's officially happening
fortnite is taking us back to chapter
one to relive the OG times surprisingly
it's actually part of the storyline of
the season so let's continue our ritual
of covering the past few months in a
season recap and if you'd like a deeper
dive into each season's narrative be
sure to click on the linked playlist to
understand the shenanigans of chapter 4
right now it's all about season 4 please
do me a favor and drop a like and maybe
a comment if you'd like more fortnite
content from me anyway you ready let's
do this fortnite last
[Music]
resort week zero after a hidden
civilization was found below our feet we
stumbled into a very much alive doctor
Sloan the woman who double crossed us
during operation Skyfire the alien
mother ship and the woman who tried to
wipe out all the Loopers during the
Collision storyline luckily she failed
both times and saw her come up and when
a giant Mech fisted her into
Oblivion um look out long story short
Sloan has officially survived and left
the imagined order and once again we've
teamed up with her to push the narrative
forward building an Intergalactic
telescope known as a stellar projector
which counted down the days to an
impending
eclipse the season began and the moon
covered the sun and the island changed
the Citadel vanished and replaced with
eclipsed estate a heavily fortified
holiday Resort home to the villain of
the Season Koo Thorn a legendary vampire
with his very own time machine we
quickly discovered he'd been traveling
back through fortnite Seasons to take
artifacts like the golden skull of King
Oro and I think that's the Hand of Midas
but his ultimate plan remained a mystery
epic games told us the fate of the
island is at stake and thievery is our
only option as look would have it a new
character arrived on the island setting
up home in a barn at frenzy Fields meet
Nolan chance and it looks like he
already knows about us a mutual friend
told me you'd be perfect for a heisting
gck you know Sloan right oh so Sloan is
the one pulling the strings yet again we
should have known Nolan chance plans to
Heist all KO Thorn's resort locations
sneaking into a guarded Vault below
ground to take back the artifacts the
vampire stole from the island we then
spend the remaining days of the first
week trying to impress Nolan testing out
K Thorn's defenses from surveillance to
turrets and the many many guards getting
in and out
unscathed the following week the truth
is revealed Nolan chance has been hired
by Dr Sloan to break into a very secret
second vault at Eclipse estate this job
though will be absolutely huge and needs
a crack team of experts to get it done
Nolan is laying low so we have to get
the team together together and it
doesn't start off well the first three
people we ask all reject us the Countess
the Arctic assassin and peely all say no
with so many rejections Nolan sets his
sight on Antonia a highly skilled rival
Thief who holds a grudge against Nolan
because he double crossed her the last
time they worked together but every
issue has a solution and a few weeks
later we realized the only way to this
girl's heart is to steal a ring from yet
another one of ko Thorn's vaults as an
I'm sorry gift uh I love it when he
grovels it was that easy Antonia is in
she's our
strategist week three was dedicated to
adding Piper Pace to the team she's a
wannabe racing driver perfect as a
Wheelman especially as she already works
as a pizza delivery driver Piper is Keen
on joining but first checks we are
serious about the task and asks us to
steal parts for a muscle car which we do
of course and now Piper is so impressed
she joins The Heist crew that makes her
employee number four
four week four it's fortnite's sixth
birthday we've been playing this game
for 6 years maybe it's time to uh touch
grass five weeks deep into the season
and another spot opens on the team Nolan
Antonio Piper and of course you who will
be represented by Penny here we still
need a bit of muscle for this job and
the news is that fish thick has moved to
the island at a Beachside house so off
we run to beg him to join the heist bruh
how do you how do you say that word Bruh
Bruh
Bruh no no no stop right there I don't
got time for any Heist until I make a
little gym for the coral buddies this
side mission has us talking to wobbly
blobs and making them a fish tank in a
basement filled with gym equipment we
fished out of rivers I honestly think
the story writers have given up at this
point anyway fish tank done fish thick
joins The Heist wow
ah week seven saw things change
massively the seemingly impossible goal
of unlocking the second Vault just
happened we got inside and as we all
thought the item Sloan want is indeed
The Time Machine the date is set to July
12th 2018 Thorn has been going back to
previous chapters again and again and
now Sloan wants that ability she wants
to time travel oh this week was also the
update that brought back f nightmares
the Halloween spooky event and we saw
with our own eyes Thorne is indeed a
vampire he protected the time machine
with his life back at HQ AKA a bar in
the farm the crew received another
member Jonesy the man who defied Sloan
to kick the fortnite story into
overdrive is back again and is willing
to help us take down a time traveling
vampire I'm not sure if he joined the
crew completely but he's definitely
around now this week we got the
attention of May a hacker who has been
working on something called a deboot van
in the wilderness north of the city this
thing looks very important keep an eye
on it she couldn't resist hacking K
Thorn servers and notices something
called Chronos cells are used to power
the time machine so like the good minion
we are we run and fight KO taking the
power cells from him so impressed with
our work May joins the crew we now have
a tech expert and the team is now huge
six people or seven if you count
Jonesy
week eight this week brought the biggest
let down in fortnite history for me we
found out that the heist we've been
planning for for weeks and weeks
happened off
camera all our hard work getting that
band back together was kind of wasted no
epic Smash and grab no epic boss fight
no epic Escape scene it just happened
when we weren't looking and now the
Vault sits empty in my opinion this was
horrendous storytelling and I'm not
happy but we do get to see the aftermath
back at the farm Not Only Had The Time
Machine been stolen but someone had
already begun using it to go back to
chapter one was this Sloan the nearest
person to it is Jones he but he won't
have done that would he anyway the
iconic durburger with the fox Clan
graffiti is now here as to our a bunch
of other artifacts it made no sense at
all but it was so cool to see chapter
one items brought back to the
world week nine and as quickly as
everything got here it all vanished all
the OG chapter one items completely gone
and so too gone is Jones I hope he's
okay and then an epic twist occurred the
items we saw in game appeared in our
world the real world at homes of
fortnite creators from 2018 Tim the
tatman received the huge tomato head
courage JD received a truck stop sign
the world's oldest gamer Dr Lup found a
huge coffee cup outside and the one and
only ninja found the most iconic prop in
fortnite history the durburger with
drift's artwork upon it the very item
that signal the start of season 5
chapter 1 I don't know about you but I
adore this kind of marketing that blurs
the lines between reality and the game
it's bloody great this week ended by
taking down the big bad of the Season KO
thorn in his monstrous Revenant form we
win he's defeated but will he be seen
again he's a freaking vampire after all
so expect to see him next fortn night
mes
It's the final week of fortnite chapter
4 season 4 Last Resort it appears that
Dr Sloan has had the time machine stolen
in order to change something in the past
but what could it be could she be
rebuilding the imagined order could she
be here to stop an event from happening
or could she be going back to the exact
date and time that Kevin the cube first
arrived in the desert all those years
ago the chances are the past is the
future and all those unexplained events
with items disappearing without without
warning was all because of this machine
I challenge you to predict the future of
fortnite what is going to happen next
season and Beyond and while you're doing
that get your butt down to the city to
this billboard here the final change of
the Season get close enough and the
original fortnite Lobby music plays it's
time to go back to the future I'm Adam
you're awesome it's been a pleasure I'll
see you LG's back in chapter
[Music]